we started doing something else we call
every single customer that places an
order now and thank them and that's it
Jersey is one of the few states where
you can actually record the conversation
of a phone call for pretty interesting
reasons I'm sure so I've been able to
actually listen to some of these things
here's how it goes hello Susan this is
Lily from winelibrary.com
I just wanted to call you and thank you
for your order hope you have a great day
uh-huh that's it have a great day bye
about 7% of the people were calling
right now are calling back apologizing
for being rude because they thought
there was going to be another huge
dropping on the phone call that's where
we got people got real cynical we're
always in sales mode see it's super
funny people are marketing right now the
way people plan weddings it's really
funny to me watching wedding planning I
bus done a lot of my wife's friends
about this I truly believe in my heart
that most people put way more time and
effort and both into planning their
running than putting energy into their
actual marriage and I truly believe that
that is the analogy of how people are
treating their business and marketing
tactics I firmly firmly believe that and
I really think about that every day I
believe that we're living through such
an unbelievable time